this has become a nightly scene in the
east jerusalem neighborhood of sheikh
vigils and protests aggressively broken
up by israeli security forces
at stake the homes of hundreds of
palestinians long subject to an eviction
campaign
the current tensions were sparked partly
by this viral video
in which local woman muna al-khud
confronts a jewish settler
you are stealing my house and if i don't
steal it someone else is going to steal
it
it was an acknowledgment of just how
close muna's family and three others are
to being forced out they've lodged a
final appeal with israel's supreme court
which is now saying it will hold another
session on monday
muna's father nabil who has already had
one house
seized by settlers fears what could
happen if the court rules against them
we'll be in the streets because all of
us like me
we are old people we don't work we don't
have incomes
and the cheapest rent around here is two
thousand dollars
how can we afford it the homes were
built for palestinian refugees in an
arrangement between the united nations
and jordan
during the period of jordanian rule
after 1948.
a jewish settler organization says the
land was owned by jews before 1948
and should be returned in light of
israel's seizure of east jerusalem
in 1967. the lawyer representing the
palestinian families
says their counter claims of ownership
have not been properly assessed by the
courts
we are dealing with the domestic legal
system that rejects
and denies the international
humanitarian law and the international
law
as should be applied in east jerusalem
the family's legal battle has been
constrained by the limits of israeli law
which israel
seeks to apply here in occupied east
jerusalem but there is another legal
argument based on
international law and israel's
obligations as an occupying power
an argument that requires political
pressure some has come from campaign
groups and diplomats in recent weeks
britain's mission to the palestinians
tweeting out this video statement
the restitution and planning laws here
and their implementation
are unfair and they breach israel's
obligations
as an occupying power since the start of
the holy month of ramadan tensions in
east jerusalem have been
unusually high from gaza hamas military
wing
is warning of a high price for israeli
actions in shakeshara
the consequences of a mass eviction here
could be felt well beyond the families
under threat
of losing their homes
occupied east jerusalem